you reacted right when I said I had
prostate cancer you had you had a
powerful reaction yeah I did bye CH I I
didn't know and if you if you got if you
got to get PR if you got to get a cancer
that's the one to get that's the one you
don't have to get it but well how are
you diagnosed just a regular checkup uh
a really interesting story when I had
H1N1 I was so toxic my wife when I
recovered was like well that wasn't
normal something's wrong with you and I
went no I had I had an infectious
disease doctor following me was H1N1
it's a terrible illness I you know it's
horrible she goes no no no I'm going to
make an appointment for you for a
physical so she makes an appointment I
before that I was seeing cardiologists
and pulmonologists and things when I
needed to that kind of thing and I go in
and he goes oh you know I was always
monitoring my cholesterol and my PSA and
all these things and uh he goes oh your
PSA went from a one to a four this year
and I was like yeah well interesting I
better go back down let me let me come
back in six months we'll test it again
he goes nah I don't feel comfortable I
go look one of the worst things for you
too is for doctors to treat special
people specially that's how you get bad
care if your doctor is in any way
changed in his or her approach to you
because you're a public person change
doctors immediately you need to be
treated with the standard of care just
like everybody else because it
adulterates our our decision- making if
we are not doing what we do always the
same way the way we know how to do it so
I accused him of of because I was a peer
and he knew who I was and I was like
you're you're you're being too
aggressive no I'm not just see urologist
I go see the urologist he goes yeah you
probably shouldn't be here you're right
but here take these antibiotics this
anti-inflammatory for a couple weeks
we'll recheck your PSA doesn't come down
goes let's do it again more antibiotics
more more anti-inflammatories still
doesn't come down and he goes well by
the book I have to biopsy you and I'm
like God damn it you see what happens
you see what happens when peer too
aggressive now I'm ending up with a
biopsy I I should have come back in 6
months had my PSA retested and we could
talk about it then biopsy cancer I was
like oh my God there's a great case
study for doctors using their judgment
right by the books I could have come
back in six months or 12 months and been
retested but it was their they had an
instinct a judgment that something was
not right and that's why you go to the
doctor for their judgment for making the
right call in the right situation I was
afraid they were being a little too
aggressive because of you you know they
were nervous they Sav your life they
they you know I was diagnosed very early
I went on active surveillance after that
for a few years uh where I was biopsied
every few months every six months which
was a joy uh and then it's I my grade
was always kind of low but it started
the volume expanded they're like all
right take it out that was that it's
good times well just stay healthy we
need you that is the plan my
friend
he